[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 28 juin voici le programme
de ce soir des tensions et des émeutes
ont éclaté dans plusieurs villes des
Yvelines cette nuit suite à la mort de
Naël un jeune de 17 ans tué par un
policier à Nanterre la mairie du
quartier du Val Fourré à Mantes-la-Jolie
a été ravagé par les flammes tout comme
la maison de quartier de Meulan en
Yvelines ont fait le point en début
d'émission Guyancourt a été une des
toutes premières villes de France à
instaurer un conseil municipal des
enfants depuis 1990 il permet aux jeunes
d'agir sur l'environnement l'école ou la
solidarité son nouveau maire vient
d'être élu on en parle dans les tuto que
de Régine ralech et chaque année près de
1500 noyade ont lieu en France il s'agit
de la principale cause de décès chez les
enfants alors à l'approche de l'été le
centre aqualudique castellia de Maurepas
a décidé de prendre le sujet à bras le
corps et de faire de la prévention et
dans cette émission également nous
parlerons de musique et plus
particulièrement de musique classique
avec le président de l'Association pour
la promotion de la musique classique à
50 ans en Yvelines on aura son président
en plateau avec nous Hervé Farge il nous
parlera notamment de l'Opéra des enfants
qui aura lieu samedi 1er juillet sera ce
sera ce samedi 1er juillet à 19h30 nous
parlerons également des animations à
prévoir cet été au domaine de Dampierre
en Yvelines et comme d'habitude de les
informations à ne pas manquer
aujourd'hui dans les dans les Yvelines
ce sera avec vous Michael ennemis
bonsoir ce sera juste après les
prévisions météo de demain matin
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera dégagé dans
les Yvelines prévoyaient tout de même
quelques nuages au niveau des
températures il fera 20 à 19 degrés en
moyenne dans l'après-midi ça se gâte
météo France prévoit des orages sur le
département avec des rafales à plus de
50 km/h côté température il fera 23 à 24
degrés en moyenne et demain nous
fêterons les marques le pont maintenant
sur les informations du jour à retenir
dans les Yvelines
et on commence ces informations du jour
Michael par les violences
urbaines qui ont eu lieu dans plusieurs
villes des Yvelines cette nuit on
commence par une image impressionnante
la nuit dernière la mairie du quartier
de du Val Fourré à Mantes-la-Jolie a été
ravagé par les flammes des tensions sont
apparues dans le quartier suite à
l'annonce de la mort de Naël un jeune de
17 ans tué hier matin à Nanterre dans
les Hauts-de-Seine par un policier lors
d'un contrôle routier le feu aurait été
maîtrisé aux alentours de 3h15 selon la
préfecture il n'y a eu aucun blessé mais
l'Annex entièrement détruite les forces
de l'ordre seront vigilantes ce soir
dans le quartier selon syndicat Alliance
police nationale d'autres violences
urbaines ont été observées hier soir à
La Verrière au Mureaux à Sartrouville
Bougival a Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
entre-z attrape lime et Poissy et
chantons les vignes on poursuit ses
informations Michael avec un peu de
politique c'est désormais officiel
othmann lassu vient de déclarer sa
candidature à la présidence de la
Fédération des républicains des Yvelines
le conseil municipal d'opposition à
Trappes et vice-président à la région
Île-de-France a affirmé son envie de
redynamiser la Fédération et de donner
un nouveau visage à la droite l'élection
se déroulera à l'automne prochain
Othman lassrude déjà entré en campagne
ces dernières semaines en multipliant
les réunions publiques à Élancourt
Versailles ou encore
Saint-Germain-en-Laye on va maintenant
prendre la direction de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des Yvelines
hier soir à Versailles c'était la soirée
annuelle des entrepreneurs à la CCI des
Yvelines sur la thématique Yvin
territoire d'excellence en présence de
son président Guillaume Kerrou au
programme rencontre avec les acteurs du
territoire l'occasion également de
découvrir le fond de revitalisation
lancée le 4 juin dernier et les deux
entreprises divinois sélectionnées par
la CCI pour accéder à ce fond rechnorak
une start-up sociale sur le recyclage et
les glaciers spécialisés dans
l'artisanat local alpérel de structures
situées à 50 ans en Yvelines les
entreprises vont toucher chacune 100000
euros grâce à ce fond d'aide pour se
développer on écoute Maxime garetta de
la CCI au micro de TV 78 pour
sélectionner les entreprises nous on a
ciblé au maximum les entreprises qui
sont dédiées sur le programme France 20
30 donc tout ce qui est rien
neutralisation en fait du territoire des
Yvelines ce qui est important également
c'est la création d'emplois donc là les
deux entreprises bénéficiaires créent
plus de 10 emplois sur deux ans ensuite
ce qu'on va regarder c'est les projets
bien sûr
l'innovation le développement de
l'activité
un nouveau comité de sélection se
réunira en septembre pour choisir de
nouvelles entreprises un mot de sport à
présent Mickaël avec un
annoncé le vélodrome national de 50 ans
les mines va accueillir une nouvelle
fois Lucie trek Champions League sur la
sapiste la structure Evinoise va
organiser la troisième manche de
l'épreuve le 4 novembre prochain
événement regroupera les meilleurs
pistards du moment et notamment les
membres de l'équipe de France et une
certaine Mathilde de gros les fans
peuvent déjà se préinscrire sur le site
internet de l'épreuve et enfin Michael
les soldes d'été
ont démarré ce mercredi 28 juin et se
termineront le 25 juillet prochain dans
les Yvelines et partout en France 4
semaines très attendues par les vendeurs
de prêt-à-porter ces dernières victimes
de l'inflation et de la concurrence
d'Internet espérialisé de bons chiffres
pendant cette période selon les
prévisions près d'un Français sur deux
devrait acheter au moins un produit
pendant les soldes on l'écoute les 5
continents au micro de TV 78 alors la
vérité c'est que je ne savais même pas
que c'était les soldes après j'avoue le
fait d'avoir vu sol ça m'a donné envie
de d'entrer dans le magasin pour moi
c'est une dérive de la société de
consommation donc je peux consommer
quand je veux je suis indépendante
pas grand chose parce qu'il y a toujours
des des sols des machins des trucs donc
pas grand chose j'achète quand j'en ai
besoin alors si ça tombe les soldes
c'est les seuls mais je vais pas exprès
ça me présente juste de l'arnaque et
c'est pousser à la consommation matraque
à quel client même maca quel client le
client ne réfléchit pas c'est les soldes
au niveau de la chaîne par impulsion
peut-être ou par addiction je ne sais
pas et vous Mathilde vous allez faire
les soldes peut-être pourquoi pas je
verrai bien s'il y a des choses qui sont
pourquoi pas attirantes on verra et vous
nickel moi oui je vais me laisser danser
je pense
merci beaucoup en tout cas Michael pour
toutes ces informations et si vous aussi
vous voyez une image ou une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
[Musique]
je vous en parlais en début d'émission
ce samedi 1er juillet l'association pour
la promotion de la musique classique à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donne son
fameux opéra des enfants avec nous pour
en parler Hervé Farge le président de
l'association bonsoir alors Hervé
combien d'enfants seront présents sur
scène samedi alors cette année il y aura
328 en France il y aura 60 choristes
adultes il y aura une soprano un ténor
et un orchestre symphonique de 55
instruments avec percussion et une harpe
puisque les enfants aiment beaucoup
entendre la harpe et nous sommes aussi
en plateau avec Pascal tevard bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur général du
domaine de Dampierre on parlera dans
quelques instants des animations à
prévoir pour cet été au domaine de
Dampierre pour l'opéra des enfants ce
sont des enfants qui viennent de quelles
écoles de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et la vingtième édition que l'année du
covid on n'a pas pu le réaliser et en
fait on veut faire de la mixité sociale
et on se rendait compte que on n'arrive
pas vraiment à faire de mixité sociale
même quand l'architecture on essayait de
mélanger les gens donc on s'est dit mais
on va le faire en montant un projet très
ambitieux mais avec des écoles et le
principe c'est une classe et une
enseignante et toute la classe est
l'enseignant participe ce qui fait que
on intervient chaque semaine on a une
des chefs de cœur qui vont de très
grandes qualités et il se réunissent
au mois de juin donc on vient de le
faire on a les 320 qui se sont réunis à
la salle jb-clément qu'on commençait à
chanter ensemble et là il se passe des
choses passionnantes parce que quand
vous mélangez des enfants de Villepreux
et puis des enfants de du valibout de
plaisir il y a des échanges hyper
intéressants et en fait il découvre
qu'il monte un projet en commun sur
quelque chose qui connaissent pas
vraiment donc ça permet en fait de
découvrir beaucoup de choses donc ils
ont travaillé sur un opéra cette année
c'est
quelle est l'histoire de cette opération
parce que c'est en fait un compte
imaginé par Étienne Perruchon qui est un
compositeur qui a écrit beaucoup de
musique de films donc c'est cette année
plutôt qu'un opéra classique comme on
avait fait l'an dernier sur Mozart la
cette année c'est vraiment un conte
musical c'est sur l'histoire d'un peuple
qui s'appelle les dogoriens donc
totalement inventé qui ont qui avait
existé dans une ville qui s'appelait
Dogora dans les langues est également
inventée
alors ça rajoute une difficulté surtout
pour les enseignants parce que les
enfants apprennent à une vitesse
ahurissante et alors nous on a des
petits sourires parce que on voit que
les enseignantes c'est à l'envers
c'est-à-dire que les enfants apprennent
très vite et trouvent que les
enseignants sont un peu longs pour
apprendre le dogorien et alors ils se
sont bien prêtés au jeu les enfants ils
ont tout de suite
si vous voulez alors la pression monte
au tout début bon c'est c'est ils
mettent du temps
de l'Opéra excusez-moi il y a pas
quelques a priori vis-à-vis non parce
que ça ça fait en fait 21 ans que on
agit la première année mais là on n'a
pas le temps mais la première année on a
fait ça c'était de la folie on faisait
sortir de 50 ans en Yvelines les gens ne
savaient pas ce que c'était qu'une salle
de ce spectacle ne savait pas ce que tu
avais qu'un spectacle il sifflet taper
des pieds etc mais ne savait pas qu'on
applaudissait quand on était content
maintenant c'est ça complètement évolué
c'est à dire que il se tiennent aussi
bien qu'elle a fait l'harmonie et puis
maintenant on a des enfants et des
petits enfants même qui dans les parents
aux grands-parents avaient participé au
spectacle et on a notamment une jeune
qui avait eu un rôle de soliste dans un
une pièce qui s'appelait Pinocchio en
2006 maintenant elle est prof de fac
elle vient nous rejoindre en tant que
bénévole pour effectivement améliorer
enfin pousser les enfants à découvrir à
se découvrir entre eux et le fait alors
du coup cette opéra des enfants ça
suscite d'évocations
c'est vraiment ça suicide évocation ça
et alors les enseignants nous disent que
les enfants changent complètement du
tout au tout c'est-à-dire quand ils ont
travaillé pendant une année sur quelque
chose
auquel ils ont aucun lien a priori et
ses enfants là même les mêmes ceux des
quartiers de Villepreux ou autre n'ont
pas vraiment l'habitude de la musique
classique et là c'est même plus du
classique c'est des choses qui sont
tellement différentes que ils sont tous
au même niveau que ce soit des enfants
d'origine du Maghreb du subsarat de
d'Italie ou autre ils se retrouvent au
même niveau il faut qu'ils apprennent
une nouvelle langue et là c'est très
amusant c'est pas l'espéranto mais c'est
du decorium
de la rigueur peut-être de la rigueur
parce que le principe c'est de les de
les amener le plus haut possible dans le
projet c'est à dire que c'est pas entre
guillemets une kermesse de fin d'année
c'est au théâtre de 51 en Yvelines on a
un contrat avec l'agglomération
tous les ans on fait un projet avec
quatre jours pour monter le spectacle
monter les décors etc etc et c'est un
projet professionnel c'est que tous les
gens qui participent sont des
professionnels et les enfants leur dit
ben maintenant vous allez monter au même
niveau que les que les professionnels
ils le sentent ils le sont ils sont pas
trop impressionnés par la scène
nationale
vous avez vous avez alors il y a trois
moments magiques le premier moment c'est
celui quand le chef d'orchestre vient
dans les classes parce que alors bon
évidemment les intérêts les chefs de
cœur qui les forment pendant l'année
leur parle du chef d'orchestre en leur
disant il faudra le regarder il faudra
bien regarder vous verrez ces gestes ce
geste là ça veut dire il faut y aller ça
c'est stoppé etc etc et donc c'est c'est
pour eux c'est un c'est une personne
très très importante et donc quand il
vient là il y a une admiration
extraordinaire alors en fait les chefs
de cœur font surtout travailler la
technique donc ça surtout par coeur
parce que eux ils travaillent par coeur
et ils critiquent un peu le adulte qui
ont une partition parce que c'est quand
même trop facile donc ils apprennent par
coeur et de là le chef commence à leur
apprendre toutes les subtilités les et
c'est là la magie de la musique c'est
que la même partition selon la façon
dont ils interprètent c'est c'est
ennuyeux possible ou au contraire c'est
enthousiasme donc il rentre complètement
et ici rentre dedans ça se passe à la
retraite complètement étranger donc ils
ont ils ont aucun a priori c'est moi qui
en a priori à la fin c'est un grand
moment d'émotion aussi bien pour les
enfants pour les familles c'est étonnant
mais là aussi on aura pour des heures
mais il y a une émotion il y a une
émotion étonnante on a des exemples qui
m'a le plus ému c'est un moment ou un
chef d'orchestre le chef est entré dans
une classe à
[Musique]
merisier à Trappes et puis dans la
classe il y avait deux grands noirs qui
étaient au fond de la classe là qu'ils
avaient deux ans de retard et pourquoi
ils avaient deux ans de retard c'est
parce que il paraît pas le français
quand ils sont arrivés en France donc il
a d'abord fallu qu'ils apprennent la
langue etc et puis donc le chef
d'orchestre s'installe et puis il
demande c'est qui ah bah oui il y a rien
à tirer c'est pas possible alors le chef
d'orchestre les a fait venir au premier
rang et là c'était une déjà les
répétitions à l'école et il leur a dit
bah maintenant vous allez chanter avec
nous et là eux immédiatement
un sourire et ils sont bien tout chanté
par cœur parce qu'ils avaient tout
appris pendant que on les punissait
derrière et on a découvert que l'un des
deux avait une voix extraordinaire et du
coup c'est devenu le héros de la classe
et puis après sur scène il a été
applaudit à tout rompre et dans la dans
la salle il y avait ses parents et alors
une émotion entre les deux parce que les
parents découvert que cet enfant qui
était toujours dernier de la classe qui
était et là tout d'un coup il est admiré
par tout le monde et inversement les
étaient ça fait partie des choses et
puis évidemment à la fin le final c'est
un final grandiose et en plus on a le
salut final et puis on tient à dire ce
sont des artistes donc on fait défiler
en fond d'écran le générique de fin où
ils ont pu leur nom et tout et là ils
sont super fiers là alors il est vrai
que la salle réacquise puisque il y a
quand même les familles qui sont
invitées puisque les familles quand on
est artiste on a le droit d'inviter des
d'avoir des invités pour la scène donc
comme eux sont des artistes et chacun a
droit à deux invités et donc ils sont
ils sont ils sont admirés la salle de
vous c'est un moment d'émotion ils
veulent tous continuer l'année suivante
donc nous actuellement difficulté c'est
plutôt de trier un peu mais ce sont des
moments magiques qui nous motivent
considérablement
je trouve ça extraordinaire enfin ce que
j'entends c'est super nous l'année
dernière on est avec accueilli la scène
nationale de Saint-Quentin et c'était
aussi un moment magique alors plus
organisé avec des adultes enfin déjà
pour nous l'ouverture vers la scène
nationale c'était important et puis ça
me rappelle une époque où on a eu un
déconfinement en deuxième déconfinement
et j'avais décidé comme on était réduit
à circuler dans le rayon de 10 km
j'avais mené une action de communication
et de miadiation à Saint-Quentin en sud
de Saint-Quentin et et les familles que
vous écrivez en fait ça me rappelle la
joie de découvrir dans pierre ce public
qui m'avait dit enfin j'ai discuté avec
tous ces gens qui disaient mais on
serait jamais venus à Dampierre si vous
étiez pas venu vers nous pour nous pour
nous montrer que dans pierre existait et
l'accès à la culture l'accès à la
patrimoine mais alors ça fait briller
les yeux ça fait les sourires et ça rend
des gens heureux et c'est ce que
j'entends et bravo pour ce 20e qui se
passe comme ça mais je l'ai vécu à
Dampierre en accueillant ses habitants
et voilà j'en ai presque l'émotions
quand ils rentrent dans le théâtre c'est
comme vous mais oui et c'est un lieu
magique et là ça me fait les enfants
qu'on accueille on n'agit pas sur le
public scolaire mais plutôt sur des
centres aérés ou des groupes de familles
qui viennent mais ils pensent pas que
voilà ça soit si accessible si facile en
plus nous c'est des grands espaces donc
ils peuvent courir et en même temps
appréhender l'histoire de la France
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau alors je le
rappelle du coup l'opéra des enfants
c'est ce samedi 1er juillet à 19h30 sur
la scène nationale du théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ils
interpréteront Dogora un opéra d'Étienne
Perruchon et pour aller plus loin il y
aura également prochainement un
documentaire à la rentrée consacrée à la
pmsq sur notre antenne pour retracer les
30 ans de l'association sur le
territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines allez
direction Versailles depuis plus d'un
siècle la librairie du quartier
Saint-Louis accueille les férus de
lecture mais elle est menacée de
fermeture car le bailleur a décidé de
tripler le loyer William Morel et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude ont rencontré
le gérant de la librairie qui se bat
pour sauver son commerce
c'est l'une des plus anciennes
librairies du département mais son
histoire pourrait bientôt s'achever la
librairie Antoine installée depuis plus
de 130 ans au 16 rue Général Leclerc à
Versailles et menaçait de fermetures la
raison le propriétaire des murs a décidé
de tripler le loyer une somme que la
librairie ne peut pas payer nous sommes
dans une période de renouvellement de
bail qui a dépassé ce qu'on appelle la
période de plafonnement et donc mon
propriétaire est en droit de demander un
déplafonnement du bail il ne veut pas me
recevoir je veux lui montrer ma limite
maximum mon modèle économique pour payer
un loyer et en aucun cas le contrer le
l'embêter j'ai une échéance c'est à dire
que je peux pas engager la librairie
dans une aventure d'un loyer triplé donc
je dois me décider éventuellement de
partir et pour cela l'échéance est au 30
juin pour sauver cette institution
versaillaise ouverte depuis 1893 les
habitants du quartier la municipalité
des auteurs des élus locaux et même
l'animatrice Laurence Boccolini ont
apporté leur soutien à l'une des
dernières librairies du secteur c'est la
dernière librairie de Saint-Louis donc
je pense que c'est très important pour
les gens du quartier d'avoir encore
cette librairie ici de ont fermé déjà
pour moi c'est très difficile à vivre en
fait on s'est beaucoup investi avec
Antoine on a créé beaucoup de soirées
littéraires on a fait beaucoup beaucoup
de choses pour cette librairie une
pétition en ligne avait déjà recueilli
plus de 1000 signatures mais Antoine
Michon le libraire à l'origine de cette
pétition a préféré la fermer il souhaite
désormais discuter avec le bailleur pour
trouver un compromis elle perdure avec
un système astucieux peut-être de loyer
progressif peut-être de loyer un peu
indissé sur son développement peut-être
moi je suis ouvert mais il faut que je
reçoive et que l'on se voit avec ce
propriétaire nous ne sommes pas ennemis
nous sommes partenaires et un
propriétaire un locataire à ce jour
aucune solution n'a été trouvée
contactée le propriétaire n'a pas
répondu à nos sollicitations
et nous avons été rejoint en plateau par
une autre journaliste de la rédaction de
TV 78 régénera les bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes en plateau pour présenter votre
educole qui vous êtes accompagné de deux
invités alors Walid basta bonsoir
bonsoir tu es le nouveau maire du
conseil municipal des enfants à
Guyancourt félicitations merci et donc
tu es accompagné par Richard Mézières
bonsoir vous êtes le maire adjoint à
l'éducation et à la jeunesse pour la
ville de Guyancourt on en parlera dans
quelques instants avec votre chronique
édulte mais avant je parle aux adeptes
déglinguettes ou bien des Garden parties
vous serez ravis d'apprendre que le
domaine de Dampierre vous ouvre ses
portes pour de multiples animations cet
été et pour en parler avec nous Pascal
Teva le directeur général du domaine de
Dampierre et donc ces animations ça
commence dès demain soir avec la soirée
guinguette qui aura lieu à partir de 19h
19h exactement à partir de m’asseoir
c'est lancement de notre de notre été à
Dampierre on commence par une guinguette
et on y en aura une deuxième le 20
juillet donc déginguettes d'ailleurs
demain soir c'est déjà complet on espère
que le temps sera bien présent avec nous
aussi et des guinguettes qui permettent
ce que je disais tout à l'heure par
exemple avec l'expérience opéra à 50 ans
c'est l'ouverture à la culture à tous
partout par tous les moyens c'est encore
on offre une guinguette on est installé
devant le château à l'ombre des
marronniers et on écoute de la musique
en mangeant une planche ou en buvant un
verre et on a le château face à nous et
c'est un moyen d'appréhender autrement
le patrimoine il n'y a pas de discours
il y a pas de conférence mais au moins
voilà c'est un moyen de s'approprier
donc là il y a les guinguettes et à
partir de du mois de juillet donc une
deuxième guinguette qui est
pré-programmée également donc là il y a
plus de place pour demain soir mais pour
le 20 juillet il y a encore de la place
pour l'instant les gens n'ont pas encore
commencé à réserver mais ça va vite se
remplir donc on peut réserver sur notre
site internet sur le site internet du
domaine de Dampierre sur la billetterie
voilà pas de souci alors le programme
sera le même
tout autre programme alors demain c'est
un DJ qui sera plus sur les années 80
mais vraiment en musique d'ambiance
c'est vraiment mes moments d'échange et
de convivialité un after work si je puis
dire qui se déroule donc de 18h de 19h
pardon à 22h et puis dans les années
pour le 20 juillet on est plus on
remonte un peu le temps plus les années
70 d'accord et alors
animation de prévu cet été c'est la
Garden Party qui aura lieu elle tout du
long du mois de juillet du 1er 30
juillet et alors là vous faites place à
l'art contemporain alors contemporain
parce que d'Empire c'est un lieu de
culture c'est un lieu de d'accueil de de
l'art historiquement ça a toujours été
enfin il y a le primatisme qui est passé
par Dampierre Salviati évidemment les
grands architectes gère dans Mansart le
nôtre et compagnie mais il y a aussi des
grands artistes au 19e siècle c'était
vraiment un centre de création et donc
aujourd'hui pour la première édition de
cette garden party on accueille à partir
de samedi prochain et bien des
sculpteurs ou des artistes contemporains
des artistes plasticiens dans les
jardins c'est un partenariat qu'on a
mené avec des acteurs communaux de la
Vallée de Chevreuse et nous on regroupe
l'ensemble de ces artistes pour
présenter dans les jardins à l'anglaise
et bien c'est installations de ces
artistes
parce que l'art contemporain doit faire
partie de de la vie de tous les jours
même dans un lieu patrimonial et donc
voilà c'est tout mois de juillet alors
c'est c'est de l'intervention c'est un
genre de Land Art c'est à dire que il y
a une artiste qui a glané des pierres
dans le parc de Dampierre et qui les
emballe avec du laine rouge et les
pauses en tapis sur sur le comment sur
omnison de la pelouse un autre artiste à
installer des lustres dans le pavillon
sur l'île un pavillon qui est en ruine
mais là des des lustres qui sont posés
là dans la serre on a une vieille serre
horticole au fond du jardin c'est une
temps enfin ce sont détentes qui sont
installées du mobilier de jardin mais
version contemporaine qui est installée
également sur l'île au milieu de l'étang
voilà différentes interventions mais qui
sont liées au patrimoine qui sont liés à
la nature qui sont liées à
l'environnement dans lequel Dampierre
est voilà c'est vraiment un accueil
convivial des artistes et cette
exposition dure tout le mois de juillet
ça vous donne envie d'y aller autour du
plateau guinguette garden party parce
que qu'est-ce qui vous tente le plus
proposer des activités on n'a pas tous
encore la chance de pouvoir partir en
vacances donc avoir des activités sur le
territoire sans avoir aller devoir aller
sur Paris voilà je pense que c'est très
intéressant et puis je vais faire une
petite pub pour Guyancourt
alors c'est notre vie VTC à partir du
1er juillet donc le weekend prochain le
10 juillet ça sera un gros événement
alors c'est moins prestigieux que que
votre château mais dans le parc de
l'Ermitage on est aussi sur sur deux
jours avec un des animations DJ des food
truck c'est une présentation
on a des sorties scolaires qui vont qui
profitent voilà on est dans le proximité
on a une chance d'avoir un département
avec une offre culturelle assez riche et
on sait que nos écoles aiment bien la
berger la bergerie dont Bouillet le
château de Dampierre tout ça donc oui
oui c'est des lieux qui sont fortement
appréciés et très appréciées
beaucoup plus classique le week-end de
pas qui vient le week-end suivant le 6
et 7 juillet on a alors là c'est la
reconstitution de la venue de Louis XV
les plaisirs de Dampierre alors là c'est
quelque chose de très costumé très cadré
parce que la course se déplace et la
cour il y a des codes et donc de deux
jours pendant le weekend où là on évolue
parmi la cour et on observe on regarde
et en participe
voilà activement aussi d'une journée de
visite de Louis XV euh Louis XV à
Dampierre évidemment elle était
parfaitement décrite parce que le
propriétaire de l'époque le duc de lui
n'était le mémorialiste de Louis XV donc
pendant 30 années le duc de Luynes a
décrit la vie de Louis XV
quotidiennement évidemment quand il
invite chez lui et que le roi vient avec
Madame de Pompadour et bien il le décrit
tout ce qui s'est passé et donc ces deux
jours on réinterprète on
réédite cette visite alors c'est on l'a
déjà fait l'année dernière c'est c'est
un classique mais on évolue tous les ans
là il va y avoir un spectacle d'escrime
il va y avoir de la musique de la danse
il va y avoir une avoir un marché de
village on essaye de trouver tous les
les petites subtilités qu'il y avait
autour de cette visite puisque c'était
pas seulement une visite de convivialité
mais c'est aussi une visite de stratégie
pour le le roi comme pour le duc et donc
le public est aussi amené à participer à
l'action
il y a des ateliers coiffure il y a des
ateliers comment couture enfin voilà il
y a plein d'ateliers qui rythme cette
promenade toute la journée tous ces deux
journées pardon et bien merci beaucoup
Pascal Thévard d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau alors les plaisirs
de Dampierre c'est le week-end du 8 et
du 9 juillet le samedi de 14h30 à 17h30
et le dimanche de 11h à 17h30 vous
retrouverez toutes les informations
pratiques sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran alors
comme chaque mercredi maintenant c'est
l'heure de l'éducole que Régine et donc
aujourd'hui vous allez nous parler du
conseil municipal des enfants qui se
passe à Guyancourt tout à fait Mathilde
est justement j'aimerais revenir sur ce
qu'est le CME plus conseil municipal des
enfants donc c'est une instance qui est
destinée aux enfants et le but est
d'améliorer la vie de la municipalité à
travers des projets et ayancourt un
maire et 35 conseillers sont élus pour
deux ans et sont généralement des élèves
de CE2 CM1 et CM2 et de 6e également
alors Walid après avoir été conseillé
pendant deux ans tu as été élu maire ce
15 juin tu as 11 ans qu'est-ce que ça te
fait aujourd'hui d'être mère est-ce que
tu es content tu es enthousiastes oui je
suis assez content
c'est une chance
d'être mère
et pourquoi est-ce que tu as décidé de
te présenter
j'ai dessiné une présenter pour
réaliser les projets de chaque élu et
faire en sorte que
la voix de chaque élu passe
partout tu as déjà des idées en tête des
des actions oui
j'aimerais installer un club de lecture
à Guyancourt
parce que j'aime bien la lecture et je
trouve que
comme on en a pas à Guyancourt
je trouve que c'est important
l'éducation donc la lecture et tout ça
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi
et justement les prochaines enfin les
dernières années il y avait tout souvent
une thématique donc l'année dernière par
exemple enfin sur les deux dernières
années le mandat portait sur la
solidarité je vous propose justement de
regarder un petit extrait
[Musique]
donc voilà on a bien vu sur la vidéo
cette petite fille qui a finalement son
goûté grâce à la solidarité alors
Richard Mézières et Walid Bastet est-ce
que vous avez une idée aujourd'hui de
sur quelle thématique va apporter le
mandat alors aujourd'hui le mandat du
CME du 7e CME va porter il faut que les
déjà que les élus travaillent entre eux
ils vont avoir des commissions à la
rentrée pour travailler en fonction des
différentes professions de poids pour
proposer des thèmes ce qu'on a pu déjà
voir et peut-être que vous voyez de Me
confirmerait on a eu beaucoup de choses
autour du harcèlement scolaire je pense
que tous nos jeunes élus sont très
sensibles et ont envie de s'impliquer
travailler pour faire être attentif aux
autres et être vigilant sur le
harcèlement scolaire je sais pas où
habite
sensibiliser un peu plus là dessus
d'habitude notre CME fait des vidéos la
vidéo qu'on vient de voir c'est eux qui
l'ont travaillé ceux qui l'ont écrit
d'ailleurs on a vu Walid en fin de la
vidéo donc c'était dans son précédent de
mon âme et donc ils vont proposer
peut-être on fait des fois des ateliers
bande dessinée on fait des défunts on
fait des dessins pardon on peut faire
une vidéo voir du théâtre voir des
animations donc ça sera aux élus du CME
de choisir sur quel mode ils vont
choisir quel mode ils vont mettre en
place pour faire ces animations autour
et on parle de harcèlement mais ils sont
aussi très sensibles à l'environnement
on parle beaucoup de ramasser continuer
à faire des ateliers autour du recyclage
du ramassage des déchets les collectes
mais c'est leur travail donc à eux de
travailler ils vont prendre des vacances
ou à l'aide a été élu le 15 juin
maintenant c'est deux mois de vacances
mais au retour des vacances un premier
similaire intégration et puis après tous
les mercredis en septembre ça reprend
alors comment est-ce qu'on fait pour se
présenter comment ça se passe
tu as fait une campagne
bah en fait
il faut d'abord
il faut déposer sa candidature puis
faire sa profession de foi
ensuite les
les enfants de
ma commune vont voter pour les 35 élus
sont tous les enfants des écoles
primaires qui votent exactement
et donc tous les enfants ont affiché des
leurs professions de foi et puis après
chacun peut lire les professions de voix
alors après quand les enfants sont de
loisirs ou quand c'est les enfants sont
dans les écoles sans partenariat avec
les enseignants les enseignants
organisent un petit peu des débats pour
que les enfants de l'école qui se
présentent puissent partager un peu leur
programme
et puis après sur la journée de vote et
ben chacun des enfants choisissent on
est là et
ça fait plus de 30 ans qu'il y a un
conseil municipal des enfants à
Guyancourt c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
premières villes en France à avoir
initié cet instant finalement vous avez
dû recul qu'est-ce que ça apporte à la
ville d'avoir un conseil municipal des
enfants ça apporte déjà de faire une
remontée de la voix des enfants
aujourd'hui il y a des certaines
sensibilités que nous en tant qu'adulte
on a peut-être pas où on n'est pas assez
vigilant mais en tous les cas d'avoir ce
conseil municipal des enfants ça nous
rappelle des fois déjà souvent à l'ordre
sur des choses qu'on a tendance un peu
oublier ça permet aussi de d'avoir un
avis sur une ville à hauteur
d'enfants
nous on voit pas forcément les choses
comme les enfants parce que pour des
raisons de taille et puis pour des
raisons d'ouverture et donc ça nous
apporte ce point de vue là
alors comment est-ce que vous les
accompagnez au quotidien dans leur
démarche début comment ça se passe
municipal de un service qui est écrit
autour du conseil municipal des enfants
avec deux animateurs et une responsable
de services donc qui font toutes ces
travail le mercredi après-midi tous les
mercredis après-midi au cours de l'année
vacances il faut quand même qu'il garde
du temps pour se reposer c'est pour ça
que c'est aussi un vrai investissement
pour les enfants parce que c'est tous
les mercredis de l'après-midi de l'année
pardon
il se réunissent en groupe entier et en
sous-groupe pour travailler sur des
ateliers donc ça c'est les services de
la ville qui les accompagne et puis on
va aussi voir des des institutions je
crois qu'à la fin de l'année il y aura
une visite à l'Assemblée nationale qui
sera organisée pour aller découvrir la
nationale et puis quand ils ont des
thèmes particuliers on peut être amenés
à les voir comment ça se passe dans une
déchetterie je crois que la dernière
fois vous avez visité à son autrui
et tout ça c'est des projets qui
t'intéressent découvrir l'Assemblée
nationale
est-ce que plus tard tu aimerais être ma
mère ou être actif dans dans la
politique
voire président
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
plateau chaque été plusieurs centaines
de noyade accidentelles touchent les
enfants de 6 à 10 ans alors pour les
éviter le centre aqualudique Castalia
situé à Maurepas a mis en place des
tests de natation gratuit comme savoir
nager la tête en dehors de l'eau sous
l'eau restez immobile ou encore sauter
dans l'eau c'est le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier
voilà continue allez regarde où tu vas
ce samedi matin pas de grasse matinée
pour les enfants
accompagné de leurs parents ils sont
plus d'une dizaine à s'être déplacés au
centre aqualudique castellia à Maurepas
pour assister à des cours de natation
l'objectif évaluer leur niveau
d'autonomie dans l'eau effectivement il
y a toujours une crainte quand on tourne
le dos ne serait-ce qu'un instant de se
dire
avant 7 ans ou avant 6 ans est-ce que
tout va bien est-ce que j'ai pas été une
attentif trop longtemps c'est le moyen
de faire le test et de voir si on peut
la laisser un peu en autonomie sans sans
être vraiment derrière à 100% et voilà
durant l'été 2021 près de 1500 noyades
accidentelles ont été recensés en France
pour ce weekend dédié à la lutte contre
la noyade des maîtres nageurs proposent
d'évaluer gratuitement l'autonomie des
enfants dans l'eau trois tests nationaux
sont proposés en fonction de leur niveau
vert le savoir nager en sécurité ça pour
nous le niveau bleu et le savoir nager
en milieu naturel ça va être plutôt le
niveau rouge donc ça permet aussi pour
nous mettre majeur de savoir en
septembre leur niveau de base et pouvoir
progresser et les faire avancer
justement dans l'objectif vers un niveau
rouge et vers un
natation correcte
nager la tête sous l'eau restez immobile
toute une panoplie de tests sont pensées
par les maîtres nageurs pour évaluer les
enfants c'était bien j'ai trouvé que je
m'étais bien appliqué
que maintenant je sais mieux faire un
peu de piscine j'ai appris l'étoile de
mer
je nage juste pour vous
j'ai mis la tête sous l'eau en passant
parce que ça j'arrivais pas encore à
l'issue de cette séance chaque enfant
repart avec un diplôme et des axes
d'amélioration pour être comme un
poisson dans l'eau
et toutes mes excuses c'était le
reportage de Régine ralech et de Julien
Leroy direction la clinique de
saint-germain-en-lay à présent où les
dialysés participent également au Tour
de France il pendant leur soin
pour valider les étapes de la Grande
Boucle un challenge bénéfique cette
fois-ci c'est le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier donc vous avez fait 65 km la
fois précédente
donc l'objectif c'est de faire au moins
ou un peu plus peut-être aussi moi je
trouve que ça serait pas mal je trouve
que ça serait pas mal pédalez sur son
lit d'hôpital c'est inhabituel et
pourtant c'est le quotidien de ces
patients en dialyse de la clinique de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye depuis 2020 en
plus des séances quotidiennes de vélo un
tour de France est organisé une fois par
an les passions se défient sur des
étapes de la Grande Boucle franchement
je suis très motivé j'ai envie de gagner
ce que vous voulez une belle coupe
exactement j'ai envie de ramener la
coupe à la maison
[Rires]
hebdomadaire plus agréable
positif pour Mohamed en dialyse depuis
deux ans les bienfaits se font ressentir
autant sur le corps que sur l'esprit
c'est bien pour le plan physique sur le
plan moral ça m'aide beaucoup ça m'a été
à maigrir ça aussi ça fait du bien pour
la dialyse en fait le son est sorti le
mieux ça dialyse mieux ça fait du 22 se
dépasser parfois même si on est fatigué
ou parce qu'avec la dialyse c'est un peu
fatigant quand même franchement c'est
trop bien moi je suis trop content
d'avoir cette chance et de participer au
Tour de France de en dialyse malgré la
fatigue la motivation ne faiblit pas et
les participants sont
au reproduisent les étapes du Tour de
France donc ça dure un peu plus de 15
jours et à la fin des 15 jours ils ont
effectué complètement leur tour de
France et donc on organise une petite
remise des prix on a à peu près presque
une centaine de patients qui participent
à ce Tour de France et donc on est très
content parce qu'ils sont assez
enthousiastes ils prennent ça comme un
challenge et comme chaque sportif
nécessite son coach le kinésithérapeute
motive le peloton c'est que parfois
c'est pas facile on a des journées un
peu plus compliquées cette fois ils ont
passé des mauvaises nuits c'est un petit
peu dur comme dans comme dans la vie
d'un sportif au final et du coup faut
parfois les motiver et il faut juste
savoir trouver les bons mots quoi mais
généralement ça passe bien reste
maintenant faut savoir qui sera le
maillot jaune du centre d'hémodialyse de
la clinique réponse le 1er juillet date
officiel du lancement du Tour allez qui
dit mercredi des cinémas et c'est tout
de suite dans votre 7 8
et pour cette page cinéma nous avons été
rejoint par une autre journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est ninja bonsoir
bonsoir je vous propose de commencer
cette page cinéma avec le coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du 7e art cette
semaine c'est le réalisateur yvelinois
Quentin Dupuis qui nous parle du tout
premier film de la saga Star Wars alors
question piège Céline on parle duquel du
coup c'est une question piège
effectivement parce que je crois qu'il y
a l'ordre chronologique et l'ordre de
diffusion des films le quatrième et bien
oui c'est bien ça je vous propose tout
de suite de regarder le coup de cœur
pour un nouvel espoir de canton Dupuis
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter Star
Wars épisode 4 uno pour un nouvel espoir
en français donc c'est le premier des
Star Wars le film originel réalisé écrit
par Georges Lucas est sorti en 1977 il
faut savoir que Star Wars c'est le
troisième film de George Lucas après son
film entre guillemets de fin d'étude THX
en 138 avec son premier vrai film
American graffiti et à l'époque non
seulement à science-fiction était un
genre qui était désuet personne ne
croyait dans ce projet c'était pas un
conseil comme des films sérieux c'était
pas conseil comme des films de cinéma et
George Lucas s'est battu et a pu grâce
au soutien notamment de Alan ladjunior à
la Fox faire ce film mais voilà il faut
savoir que aujourd'hui ça paraît évident
Star Wars mais à l'époque c'était
vraiment personne ne croyait ni en lui
ni dans le projet et personne ne
comprenait ce qui voulait faire
[Musique]
que les films de George Lucas et Star
Wars sont aussi beaucoup inspirés par
les films de Samurai d'Akira Kurosawa
dont il était un grand fan c'est le film
qui m'a donné envie de faire du cinéma
que j'ai vu quand j'étais tout petit et
surtout ce qu'on oublie beaucoup au-delà
de au-delà de Star Wars en tant que tel
on oublie souvent le côté technicien
quelque part de George Lucas qui arrive
Sony toute l'industrie derrière la
caméra c'est à dire que sans George
Lucas on n'aurait pas du son numérique
au cinéma aujourd'hui on n'aurait pas de
projection numérique on aurait pas les
effets spéciaux tels qu'on les connaît
c'est en grande partie pas que mais en
grande partie grâce à lui grâce à la
création de sa société ILM que
aujourd'hui on a les Marvel on a les
d'ici on a tous ses films avec les
effets spéciaux qu'on connaît parce qu'à
l'époque ça coulait pas de source et
c'était un des un des pionniers à la
fois continuer à faire beaucoup de
maquettes
et de marionnettes à l'ancienne et aussi
à pousser les effets numériques
notamment la séquence du briefing où la
princesse Leïa et le général montrent
les plans les toits noirs c'est de la
première séquence entièrement générée
par ordinateur d'histoire du cinéma
c'est le film pour s'évader c'est le
film qui nous fait voyager c'est le film
qui nous montre que une galaxie autour
de nous et plein de belles choses à voir
et ça fonctionne surtout qui donne de
l'espoir
[Musique]
on poursuit cette page cinéma avec les
films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
c'est avec vous Céline Charl et pour
commencer vous nous proposer le retour
du plus célèbre des aventuriers et oui
Mathilde Indiana Jones est de retour
pour une ultime aventure un film qui
devrait ravir les nostalgiques de la
saga le célèbre archéologue revient
après 15 ans encore et toujours sur les
sous les traits du charismatique
Harrison Ford Alger maintenant de 80 ans
il en avait 79 quand il a tourné ce film
dans ce cinquième opus on est en 1969
Indiana a fait équipe avec sa filleule
Elena pour sauver le cadran de la
destinée des griffes des nazis alors le
cadran c'est un artefact qui permet de
localiser les failles spatio-temporelles
leur antagoniste un scientifique nazi
joué par Maz Mikkelsen veut son emparer
pour changer l'issue de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale les deux compères les
deux compères vont donc se lancer dans
une aventure rocambolesque tantôt en
moto tantôt en tout tout ou à cheval
action et humour sont au rendez-vous
regardez il est arrivé dans ma vie de
voir
des j'ai subi des tortures vaudou
[Musique]
j'ai pris 9 balles donc une fois par ton
père
je suis désolé
mais ça je l'ai cherché
toute ma vie
à noter d'ailleurs ketan Isidore un
jeune acteur Yves Linois a eu la chance
de partager quelques scènes avec
Harrison Ford dans le film et bien c'est
un chanceux vous nous proposez un autre
rendez-vous Céline à présent avec une
comédie dramatique italienne oui vers un
avenir radieux c'est encore un film qui
parle de cinéma cette année ça semble
être le thème de prédilection des
réalisateurs le film se concentre sur
Giovanni un cinéaste sexagénaire reconnu
il plonge sur son nouveau film sur le
communisme italien de l'après-guerre
mais ce prodige du cinéma est également
en crise existentielle sa femme le
quitte sa fille sort avec un homme qui a
trois fois son âge son producteur est
farfelu et un poil endetté en bref le
monde est absurde des rangs je venir à
l'heure et capricieux le réalisateur du
film Nanny Moretti se moque gentiment de
lui-même dans ce film c'est un peu une
mise en abyme chargée de nostalgie sur
le cinéma et sur la société et ces
changements regardez
[Musique]
quand les chaînes d'amour
notre rendez-vous est confirmé chez
Netflix
[Musique]
et on termine votre sélection Céline
avec Chonchon le plus mignon des cochons
c'est un film d'animation en stop motion
oui on suit l'histoire de Babs 9 ans qui
rêvent d'avoir un chiot à la place son
grand-père qu'elle vient juste de voir
débarquer lui offre un animal de
compagnie un peu plus original un petit
cochon bah ça a grandi dans une famille
vegan et écolo c'est donc tout
naturellement que chanson son nouvel
animal va devenir son meilleur ami mais
son grand-père ne semble pas partager
les mêmes intentions dans le village le
concours de charcuterie organisé chaque
année pourrait bien venir perturber
l'équilibre de la famille un film drôle
et léger sous fond de militantisme il
aborde des thèmes comme le respect des
animaux de l'écologie ou encore de la
force des liens et bien merci beaucoup
Céline Charles pour votre sélection
comme chaque semaine des films à ne pas
manquer dans les salles de cinéma une
préférence moi j'aimerais bien avoir
Chonchon
c'est vrai que ça aborde un terme en
plus sous un côté un peu humoristique et
un terme important voilà et vous
Mathilde moi j'irai voir Indiana Jones
la 5ème
et c'est bientôt la fin du 7 8 mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
matin le ciel sera clairsemé dans les
Yvelines côté température il fera 19
degrés à Rambouillet et 20 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Versailles
dans l'après-midi soyez prudent mettez
au France annonce des risques des
risques d'orage dans le département
niveau température il fera 23 à 24
degrés en moyenne et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]